one of the joys of this week was
definitely the bernie sanders meme
for sure so it started when a
photographer captured bernie looking
very bundled at the inauguration and
then the internet fell
in love with that little bernie nugget
and put him everywhere
in the park with some pigeons there you
go
there's bernie on the subway hi
this one's my favorite bernie on a
celestial seasoning sleepy time tea box
that one really really gives me
everything until i saw this
it rivals bernie joining the cast of sex
in the city yeah we found our new
samantha
exactly there you go and guess what
what we have bernie at the news desk
with us ross so hi
he looks right at home and you know
those those mittens are actually from a
company in vermont
and they're made from repurposed
sweaters of course so i can somebody
make mittens up for me out of this when
i
like thank you also you look like we're
celebrating with that silver mylar pop
and um
i love a celebration of course you do
okay drew guess what we have a guest
here at the news desk today and she's
got an interesting connection
to you the internet is freaking out over
joe ellen pellman the star of the prom
on netflix hello
yeah okay so basically twitter
thinks that you two are twins look at
that right there what do you think
when i see this side by side i do see it
you do right yes
i'm and what an honor gosh she's the
most beautiful i
so i feel honored to even be in that
well you're not so proud
of himself honey and like and she's so
good in the prom so
good right take a look at beautiful
joe allen in the prom check this out
that was insane i know i'm really
freaking out
don't freak out we have a plan remember
we're gonna get dressed up and go to
prom and be together
in public not hide anymore
are you sure about this there's only one
thing i'm sure about
well there she is that's the beautiful
joe ellen pelman are you there
yes i'm there hi drew
[Applause]
oh my gosh it's so i'm like thrilled
to be here um this is a dream come true
you're gonna fit
i was watching the prom and when you
were watching meryl streep nicole kidman
andrew reynolds james corden
and then this star floats down
from the heavens and lands before our
eyes
my goodness you have got to have the
goods to
rise you know to meet let alone go
above and beyond those incredible
superstars and you do
yeah thank you oh my gosh thank you so
much for your kind words
um it really was like every single day
on set
felt like a master class i was just
trying to like observe and listen
and you know to these amazing co-stars
and just like watch them do their thing
and like watch
like what makes meryl merrell and like
how fearless
nicole is every day on set was the best
day of my life
i heard you say that meryl streep never
does the same thing twice
will you tell us about that because i
always want to know what like a fly on
the wall gets to see with meryl streep
um my first day ever filming with her it
was the scene in the hotel lobby
where um i tell them that i'm going to
speak my truth my way and then meryl
just like screams at me and it was just
fantastic to watch her like she
did a new scream every time she did
something new every single way she said
the line was different and there was
like a different inflection
a different intention and like everyone
else just sort of like played off of her
she really like set the tone
for how this process was gonna be and it
was just gonna be like we're gonna try
something new on every take everything's
gonna be
fun and different and then um
i mean nicole she's just like the
definition of fearless
she um had this idea that she was gonna
eat the ice cream
in our scenes like with her hands and
every single take she would like stick
her hand in the pine of ice cream and
eat the ice cream
every single take i was like wow okay
she
is committed she is dropped in thank you
for that
you